- I love this outfit.
- Thank you.
- [Kelly] I'm going to steal it.
- [Kelly] Oh my God, have you met Ben?
- Well just now.
- Just now.
- Hey, you go way back.
- I'm a big fan of Drop Dead Diva.
- [Kelly] What do you have?
- Aw, are you really?
- I totally am, ahh.
- That's awesome
(everyone laughs)
- It's a Lifetime show.
I met your husband obviously
a bunch of times, I beieve.
- That's right you guys
were sort of, you know-
- In the same family, in
fact he was the last person
to touch my wife's belly
before we had our, our--
I was there, I was there,
it was totally consensual.
(Kelly laughing)
Before we had our first child.
- He is the most
inappropriate human being.
- No, no, no, I think he
like willed it into being.
- You know everybody says that--
- She was only 14 weeks pregnant.
- They're like, "Oh no,
it was really sweet"
and I'm always like, "No
it's not, he's creepy"
- No, you know what, but you
know what, in turn though
I totally creeped him out.
I ran into him at the
NFL honors and I was just
so excited and I didn't
know I was gonna see him
and I was like, "Oh my
God, hi, I'm Kelly."
And then I started acting weird so I left.
But he was so nice.
- Dude, that's what I did to you.
That is what I did to you.
- Wait, when?
- Yes, when you met Meryl--
- I embarrassed myself.
- [Ryan] No, you did not because--
- She's so scared of me.
- No, she's not, she's not.
- [Kelly] Look at how intense my eyes are.
- No, no, well okay.
- It's like I wanna wear her skin.
I don't.
- Your eyes were very intense cause I--
- They were, I didn't
expect it to happen y'all,
I'm not around actors
ever, until now, this show,
but I'm like never, I'm
usually around musicians.
- It was actually a thing
of beauty because I was
walking this way and I
didn't realize that Meryl
was over here. How?
I don't even know.
But you were here and
your eyes were saucers
and I was like " Oh my God it's Kelly."
And for a minute I thought you were like,
eyes were saucers for me, I was like,
"How does she know, its me?" (laughing)
(all laughing)
- Sorry, I'm so sorry, I freaked out.
- And then I walked, and I'm
like "it's Kelly Clarkson"
and you turned to me and you
were like, "I just met Meryl."
And I was like--
- Oh my God, I blacked out
I don't even remember that,
I blacked out.
- And then I proceeded to black
out, so we both blacked out.
- I blacked out, I was like,
I mean poor other girls,
they were just standing
there and I was like,
"And Meryl, hi".
- [Ryan] I would've done the
same thing, wouldn't you?
- I actually have met her
and blacked out as well.
- See? You black their memories out.
- [Kelly] She has that.
- When I met her she actually
told me I was annoying
cause she saw, it was a play that I was in
and she meant it as a
compliment but the first words
ever from Meryl Streep
was " Oh my God, you
"were so annoying."
(all laughing)
- Are you dying?
Cause I'm dying for him, I'm like so-
- She meant it as like "good job".
- Of course she did.
- Here's what I would've taken from that,
"She saw me in a play".
- Yes.
- That's what I would've taken from that.
- Yes, after a few months of
therapy, that's what I took.
- [Kelly] That's amazing,
What do you have?
- Speaking of therapy...
We heard about the knee
gash and the whole thing,
and the dumplings and sooo--
- [Kelly] Oh you're nice.
- There's dumplings.
- Yes.
- [Kelly] Dumplings.
(crowd cheering)
- Oh, it ended happy.
- You get a dumpling.
- Thanks, everybody gets a dumpling.
- And everybody gets a dumpling.
- That's so nice.
- It's the first season,
we can't give cars yet.
- Oh my, this is the coolest thing ever.
- This is so y'all get something.
- [Kelly] Oh my gosh it's so nice.
See, it ended well.
- Uh hmm.
- See, look, are they good?
- All of that, uh hmm--
- [Kelly] Oh my God.
- and they're good, these are
real, they're not like props.
- No, but you said that
Sterling, your husband freaks
people out, I freaked him out.
He probably doesn't even remember.
Or maybe he's like, "Don't
get near Kelly Clarkson"
I don't know.
- Oh he would never say
that, he would never.
He would say, "Don't
you embarrass me on that
"Kelly Clarkson show".
That's what he would say.
(Kelly laughs)
- I love it, we have very
similar, like wooh, we're
both like that.
I love you.
- I love you too.
We should go out but not
anywhere where there's a lot
of people.
- [Kelly] Yes.
- Like places that are like devoid--
- Cause then we'll get
all those people going,
"you're annoying".
(all laughing)
- And we're like, "Us?, whatcha mean?"
- But a good time, you're jealous.
- We would have a good time.
Y'all would be jealous of
us, wouldn't you? (laughs)
- Yes, so would Meryl.
We would have so much fun.
- Meryl's gonna call, you
wait, Meryl's gonna call us
and wanna hang out.
- I'm gonna put it on the vision board.
- She wouldn't use a
phone, she's above phones.
- She's above phones, she
just thinks about you.
- Do you think maybe
she's one of those people
that no one ever calls her
because everybody thinks
that they're not cool
enough for Meryl and she's
like really super lonely?
And just waiting for you and me?
- I don't think lonely,
she's got like a big family.
I think she got a lot
of kids and stuff yeah.
- Crushing every dream, every dream.
(Kelly laughs)
- But wait, you've got a new
show out "First Wives Club".
- Yes.
- On BET plus.
(audience applauds)
- Oh, thank you guys.
- And I gotta tell you,
literally, I like after
seeing the movie, like
friends that we all, there are
like four friends and we all
got little pearl necklaces,
just like...
I love that movie, it's so good.
Is it based on that? The movie?
- It is and I have to say
they did a really, really
good job because you know
reboots can sometimes feel
like retreads of like the same?
But what they did was they took the energy
and the excitement and the
love that everybody has
for that movie, admittedly
so, and then they just use
it as a backdrop.
And there's Easter eggs
but really it's a homage
to the movie as opposed
to like a reboot so it's
really smartly done.
- I'm excited, that's great.
- I'll be on season two.
(audience applauds)
- [Ben] That's awesome.
- [Kelly] That's so great.
(audience applauds)
- So also, speaking of
the original cast of
First Wives Club, I hear
you ran into Goldie Hawn,
which is awesome.
- [Ben] What?
- I would've just started saying lines
from Bird On A Wire, like all the films
from my childhood.
- She doesn't do well
with meeting icons though.
- I don't either, I don't
know if you've noticed.
(Ben laughs)
- Well, it was a good thing
we weren't there together.
First of all, it's
embarrassing cause I was
at the psychic's.
- You were at a psychic?
- A psychic, not a side
kick, I was at the psychic.
Cause I was like just
tell me that everything
is gonna work out in my life, you know.
And I guess Goldie wanted
to know that everything
was gonna work out in her
life and it was right when
Kate had had the next, her
third baby, the little girl
and all I could think,
the door opened, and there
she was and I was like,
"I know my psychic isn't
Goldie Hawn".
(all laughs)
You know what I mean?
For a minute I was like, "Maybe it is".
- [Kelly] Wouldn't that be amazing?
- That would be so amazing, that's where
our brains at right?
- Exactly.
- And then I just I realized
she wasn't the psychic
and then I was like, "Oh
my God, congradulations
on your baby girl".
(all laughs)
- What did she do?
- She did this, she was like, "Thank you".
- That's kinda how I feel
Meryl got scared of me.
I was loud though, she
should've been scared.
I was excited.